5 55 and your friday morning we're
taking the pulse of the neighborhood on
that project where the
95 meets the northern 215 beltway come
on let's go
centennial bowling well in a completely
unscientific poll i asked the centennial
hills facebook group for their thoughts
on the project how
it's affected their lives beck's
commented it's great can't wait for it
to be done
the construction will make life easier
getting on the 215 for the 95. don't
mind it plus it's job security for our
blue collar folks
from carroll all the building going on
in centennial hills is bringing in a lot
of people
creating the need for that giant freeway
system and also bringing in
more crime cindy concludes hey you still
can't go north after a walmart trip
pretty sure that will change by the time
the project is in the history book cindy
but that is three years from now
if you want to weigh in we'd love to
hear from you just look for this story
on my facebook page
at bow tie nate as well as the eight
news now facebook and twitter pages
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com